the major producer of breast implants is
stopping the sale and distribution of
its textured products amid growing links
to a rare and deadly cancer the FDA
requested the voluntary recall from
Allergan after a significant increase in
cases of a particular lymphoma CTM
consumer investigative correspondent
Andrew Warner has been looking into
questions surrounding these textured
implants for the past two years now so
Anna I know you're on top of this but
why is this recall taking place right
now well the FDA Gale says the risk of
lymphoma with Allergan's bio cell
textured implants is approximately six
times that of other manufacturers
marketing in the US now women with this
cancer have been pushing the FDA to pay
attention for some time but even though
textured implants have been pulled in
other countries only now is the u.s.
getting up to speed had we known of a
risk yeah we would have never opted to
have an implant
Lori daddario had already beaten breast
cancer then in 2017 two years after
getting textured implants following
reconstructive surgery
she says her right breast suddenly grew
to three times its normal size the
swelling was so rapid and so pronounced
that I knew that it I just knew that it
wasn't normal she underwent a battery of
tests the results cancer which developed
around her breast implants that was
total shock and even now sometimes I go
how can that be
daddy Rios implants were manufactured by
the company Mentor she's one of a
growing number of women being diagnosed
with the rare disease known as breast
implant associated anaplastic large cell
lymphoma associated with the textured
form of implants the FDA on Wednesday
asked a different company Allergan to
recall its textured implants linking
them to significant patient harm
including death the agency says of 573
lymphoma cases 481 are attributed to
Allergan implants and the FDA also
reports that at least 12 of 33 patients
who died had Allergan implants Allegan
told us it's voluntarily recalling it's
by
sell textured implants and tissue
expanders worldwide as a precaution is
one of the theories that this just kind
of irritates and inflames the
surrounding tissues it is one of the
theories because of this surface phase
right that's right
in March we spoke with Texas breast
surgeon dr. Elizabeth Potter who even
then refused to use any textured
implants
I won't place them actually in my
practice we often say if this doesn't
pass the sister test doesn't pass the
sister test ie that's correct and give
it to your sister you're not going to
give it to your patients that's correct
daddario is now 58 and cancer-free but
she says the recall does not go far
enough one person with this lymphoma is
one too many the FDA is not recommending
that women without symptoms remove the
implants because of the risks of surgery
but dr. Potter tells us many patients
want them out she has removed them so
far for 35 women mentor stands by it's
textured implants and says the cancer is
rare with its implants but one is too
many I love the the sister tests that
she was talking about so for women who
will have the textured implants or maybe
you have implants and you don't know
what kind you have what should you do
really doctors are saying you should
monitor for symptoms if you have
swelling if you have pain something
unusual something unexplained go to your
doctor and make sure to get that checked
out or if you have questions you can go
to your doctor and ask questions about
all of this and whether your implants
might be something you need to look at
or not that's right one case is too many
in it thank you very much we appreciate
it